remembering
and amnesia
each one of us has a unique
finding a unique
union
our own style
having unique
signposts up the different
paths on the mountain having
unique concepts in our
lattice work
therefore the recognition of the diamond
necklace that is already around our neck
is unique for every single
one of us
and that remembering as the greek said
an amnesia which is remembering whereas
amnesia is the forgetting
is so profound and that's why the sufi
metaphysic
what that al wujud
about a little over a month ago caused
my profound sadori
because i'd built up all of these
different signs
on these different paths to the one end
all of these different concepts in my
lattice work
and when william chidik wrote in the
piece on the ibnarabi society that what
that aloo jude is not just the unity of
all being the unity of all existence
but it's the unity of all finding
that was
for me just was oh my gosh
alan's gone atlas is gone this is all
one consciousness holy cow that has been
colored by experience
each one of us with their own unique
remembering our
own unique style of finding and it's the
integral or the summation of
all eight billion unions
as what what that aloo means
and if you go even further outside of
this creation design outside of this
illusion this dream this appearance
all of the other creation designs all of
those other dreams
appearances and illusions there are also
the individual agents
there that are undergoing their own
unique styles of remembering
of an amnesia of finding
and so it's the integral or the
summation of
everyone's finding
you can think across all creation
designs
that's how fast finding is happening in
all of these unique styles of
recognizing the diamond necklace that is
already around the neck
of awareness of consciousness
it took me so long to ask the question
what is the i
is the eye shared
and so much civilizational
propaganda around separation
around the individual
contracted entity
not once being introduced to the
possibility
that the i the consciousness the
awareness itself is shared
it took me a lot longer to get to what
is i
than it did for me to get to what is my
source what is my source
is a question that is a lot easier for
people
because we come from the same source
and that's very evident and very obvious
even if people say that my source is my
mother and father
then we ask who who is their source who
is their source who is their source
and it keeps going back in that great
chain of being to the same source
we all come from the same source
and so therefore
question what is i becomes easier
because you add a pair of
eyes to the source as it creates
this dream this illusion this creation
design
this appearance of physicalism
aka as quantum mechanics is saying all
is energy
all is no thing and so
as that source is immersed
into aka us these creation designs
it makes more sense when you attach an
eye
the eyes to the question what is i
to that source or god or
infinite or tao or brahman
expressing itself and that all of us
share the i we share the i
if you look at the pupil the pupil is
the
shared eye whereas the iris around the
pupil is the unique
coloration it's the unique gem
that is around each of our necks that
the source light
comes and refracts through and that is
our unique
experience that is our unique expression
and that's what the greeks meant by know
thyself
the delphic maxim written on the top of
the temple of apollo at delphi
is know thyself and it doesn't mean to
oh who is alan who is atlas who is
this and what is this going to do in the
world
it's not that it's who is the i
who is the god who is the source what is
that self and how is that self
shared
and that naturally creates the
recognition that it's the same
source light refracted through our all
of our diamond necklaces
as the unique expression of what this
atlas
is
and that's a big difference between
knowing that you are that
we are that i am that
and that that is like a source light
refracting
through each of our diamond necklaces as
a unique expression
versus the way that i and many of us are
indoctrinated into civilization
as saying that you are alan which is
separate egoic
entity amongst other separate goat
entities in
a finite planet that
we have no idea what our sources we have
no idea
who we are we have no idea where we're
going
and that's why the perennial wisdoms
across the planetary mystic traditions
point to the same one end across these
different faces of the mountain these
different
paths that have different signposts
and the more that you take in these
different signposts across these
different paths
the more of a robust lattice work you
make so that you get your unique style
of finding you get your unique style of
remembering
of an amnesia and that's when you pierce
the veilless
veil the gateless gate
which we'll unpack here in a moment
the parable of the prodigal son is so
important here because
we seek externally especially in that
indoctrinated
style that were baptized into the
physicalism of civilization
where it's seek for happiness externally
and that's the parable of the prodigal
son where you hit a breaking point
and you turn back inward and then you
investigate your own awareness your own
consciousness and you recognize that i
am god
you are god we are god we are source we
are the infinite we are dow we are
brahman expressing itself in these
illusions these creation designs these
dreams these appearances
each of us with that unique diamond that
the source light is refracting through
that is creating our experience our
expression
again that iris coloration around the
pupil
and so it's that turn inward that turn
inward turn inward inward
that is so critical it's so critical the
earlier you do that turn inward the less
you're going to suffer
seeking happiness externally you have an
infinite well of honey that is just
located
underneath of the rock
and the rock is the egoic separate
entity
move that out of the way and tap in
to the infinite well of honey
that well of honey is the 24 7
happiness peace child like
awe and wonder and creativity and
imagination
and play this is lila the divine
play the cosmic play
eternally an eternal cosmic play
and this is one expression of it
again these perennial wisdoms like the
parable of the prodigal son they run
so deep and modernity
with so many 15 year olds 25 year olds
35 year olds even 45 year olds even
adults
have never studied these perennial
wisdoms
and that's why they're contracted egoic
entities
they've never taken the time to go full
time on truth
when you go full time on truth truth
yields
but when you only go one hour a week on
truth while you spend the other
dozens of free hours a week that you
have consuming
polarization propaganda or other vapid
content
you are inevitably not going to
pierce that veilless veil and so what do
we mean by veilless veil
or gateless gate or the flat mountain
is that
as much as there is a veil as in there
is a forgetting
or there is an amnesia
and then our role is to
pierce that veil in order to remember
to undergo an amnesia that that
veil itself doesn't even exist
that's why it's the veiless veil it can
only be reported
as piercing a veil or walking through a
gate of some sort
but the gate itself is gateless
that's why when we talk about this
mountain when we talk
about all these different paths with all
these different signposts pointing to
the one end across
all of the perennial wisdoms
that that mountain is actually flat that
that mountain
is just this happening it's just this
appearance that's what nonduality is it
is just this appearance there is no
mountain
but the dualistic concession is that
there is
a mountain there are people that have
underwent union at a much deeper more
profound level with the absolute with
god with infinity with source with tao
with brahman
and those are typically the people that
you as
you undergo the process of wanting to
god realize those are the people that
you want to surround yourself with those
are the people that you want to learn
from
as quickly as possible dedicating
yourself full time to truth
so that you can also god realize so that
you can also remember
yourself as god as source as infinity
expressing itself
at that in amnesia
and this goes back to that simultaneity
that we talk about
so much on the program simultaneously
it's the flat non-dual with the
dualistic concession of the mountain
simultaneously there is a veil of
forgetting
so many people in this contracted egoic
separate entity
at the same time that it's absolutely
veilless
the same time that there is a gate
to undergo an amnesia and to pierce the
veil and to remember
at the same time that it's completely
gateless
and the question another one
to ask that's so profound that also was
just so
recently just
just embody just just blown
them that nirvana
to be blown out to be blown away the
moksha
the liberation from suffering satori
enlightenment where the light bulb
doesn't just flicker but it stays on
because you [ __ ] get it you got it
and you don't need a gold star from a
teacher
on your forehead that says that i got it
no you just got it and you no longer
need any type of validation
a lot of these wisdoms that we're
talking about right now came from the
recent interview we did with fred davis
who's an
incredible non-dual spiritual teacher
and the recent interview that we did on
non-duality and awakeness
where we went through this process of
understanding these veils veils these
gateless gates these flat mountains
these bubbleless bubbles
the simultaneity of the non-duality and
the dualism the dualistic concession
and even just unpacking this a couple
videos ago which you can watch
in that direct path number 10 where we
talked about the difference between
near guna brahmin versus saguna brahman
which means the absolute without
attributes versus the absolute with
attributes and how you hold both of
those at the same time
or like we just did in the last video on
the most important symbol ever made
which is that taijitsu or the yin yang
which has the monism with the dualism
all in one symbol the profundity of that
and so you get to this question is this
an appearance of infinity
is this an appearance of god is this an
appearance of source
is this an appearance of tao of brahman
is this god's dream
is this what these are these creation
designs
and we are that undergoing this process
this appearance
and when you get to that
um
you really know that diamond necklace
that's around your neck you really know
and it's so embodied that you can't help
but be
happy you can't help but be peaceful
you can't help but have child like awe
and wonder
and be have this motivation to
architect the maximal prosperity and
abundance
and well-being and flourishing for the
entire civilization
you can't help it that's the natural
channel that comes through
once you know
that's why it's wu wei it's effortless
action
that channels through it's the absolute
highest god morality that channels
through
in those architectures in the butterfly
effect of that peace and that happiness
to your family to your friends to your
co-workers to people online to your
community to the world
it requires these big questions it
requires the question what is my
source and to go back and go back and
back
back and recognize that now what is the
i is the
i itself shared is the observer the
witness
the i am the consciousness the awareness
itself
shared is that pupil shared while the
iris is the unique coloration the iris
is that unique diamond around the neck
that is experiencing the white source
light refracting through it as a unique
expression
and to be fluent in things like the
parable of the prodigal son to
understand to not seek externally for
happiness
but to seek internally inward where you
remove that
rock and you find that infinite well of
honey
that is what your consciousness what
your awareness is
and recognizing that all 8 billion in
this creation design
are undergoing their own unique styles
of finding
and to take the summation of all of
those unique styles of finding the
integral of it
that is what what that would sufi
metaphysic
means
each one of us having our own unique
style of finding
with our own unique exploration of these
different
paths these faces with different
signposts different concepts in our
lattice work
and piercing that veilless veil to that
one end that gateless gate
that flat mountain true
simultaneity the non-duality
and the dualistic concession as one
as one
and recognizing our eternity
recognizing this as an appearance of
infinity of god
of source of brahman of tao
this is the remembering this
is the an amnesia
piercing through the veilless veil the
gateless gate
climbing up the flat mountain
and in doing so
truly knowing thyself
truly knowing thyself knowing thy source
and knowing what the i is
knowing that this is the god this is the
source this
is infinity dao brahman expressing
itself
as a dream as an illusion as an
appearance
and each of us having our own unique
diamond around our necks that the source
light is refracting through
but each of us is a diamond
undergoing our own unique remembering
our own
unique and amnesia our own
unique finding
the unity of all finding
so about four years ago or so
i was played the song remember
by omkara by one of my
just most loving friends who's an
incredible
curator as a psychedelic psychotherapist
and back in 2016
when i went underwent my first 5meo dmt
experience
which i've been through about half a
dozen now
when this song played
remember by omkara
in her playlist
it's like
it hits you and you and you get it
but you don't get it
because you haven't built up those
signposts and those paths and that
framework to understand it fully but
it's
resonant it resonates
you can tell it's so beautifully it's
like the tuning fork
it's just perfectly tuned to the
resonance of what
the absolute is the song
but four years ago you don't have the
words to be able to explain
the feeling of it but now you have the
symbols the words because you've
experienced satori
moksha nirvana sahaja
you've experienced it and now you're
able to communicate it with so much more
profundity
and you actually understand the song
at a new deeper level so i'm gonna go
ahead and play
remember by omkar right now and i'm
gonna i'm gonna sing along a little bit
i encourage you to as well
the link is in the bio below to go and
listen to it yourselves
and i'm going to just play it from the
computer speakers because i don't want
to get a copyright
strike on this so join me
if you would like biggest of love
i'll end the video in a moment for us
this life is
this life is
this life is a dream
it'll be a dream
it'll be over in the blink of an
eye
[Music]
remember who you are
[Music]
remember what you are
life is this
whose hands are the
whose voices this
what
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
wow
well i hope this brought you value
i love you thank you
like the video subscribe if you haven't
comment below with your thoughts i'd
love to hear from you
share it with people that you feel would
resonate
ask these questions
remember
i love you thank you
wow
you